GREG: I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS.
LET'S MOVE ON.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
THANK YOU.
SO, LIKE A 6-POUND FROZEN BLOCK
OF IN-FLIGHT BATHROOM WASTE
JAMES COMEY'S BOOK DROPPED FROM
THE SKY.
[LAUGHTER]
AND WHEN IT DID THE MEDIA COULD
NOT CONTAIN THEIR EXCITEMENT.
>> THE JAMES COMEY BUT ACTUALLY
CAME OUT EARLY.
>> OH, GOOD EVENING, RACHEL.
I WANT TO SEE HOW THE
INVESTIGATION TURNED OUT.
>> BREAKING NEWS, THEY CAN READ.
GREG: NO ONE SAID ME A BOOK AND
EVERYONE ELSE GOT ONE AND IT
MADE THEM FEEL SO FUNNY INSIDE.
>> COMEY WENT FURTHER THAN YOU
WERE EXPECTING EVEN MORE SO THAN
WHEN HE TALKED ABOUT IN THE
BOOK.
>> HE IS NOT FULLY BACK ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN ANY WAY,
SHAPE OR FORM.
>> HE TALKED ABOUT HOW THE AUTO
BODY EXPERIENCE AND IT MUST'VE
BEEN AN OUT OF BODY EXPERIENCE.
>> THEY KEEP SAYING THAT SIX
KIDS, THIS AIN'T THE BIBLE.
IT'S A FREAKING BOOK OF GOSSIP
BY A BETTER ASKED.
HERE'S ONE REVELATION.
COMEY SAYS COMPROMISE ABOUT
SOMETHING.
>> I THOUGHT OF NEW YORK MAFIA
SOCIAL CLUB.
THE ITALIAN MAFIA CALLED ITSELF
[INAUDIBLE] AND THEY DRAW A LINE
BETWEEN SOMEONE WHO IS A FRIEND
OF YOURS MEANING SOMEONE OUTSIDE
THE FAMILY AND SOMEONE WHO WAS A
FRIEND OF OURS MEANING AN
OFFICIAL MEMBER OF THE FAMILY
AND THE PRESIDENT-ELECT IS
TRYING TO MAKE A SAME THING AND
THAT MADE IT A THING OF OURS SIX
T-SHIRT RACHEL READ THE ENTIRE
BOOK AUDIENCE.
IT WAS LIKE A BEDTIME STORY FOR
COMMUNIST PARTY CAT LADIES.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT TRUMP IS LIKE A MAFIA BOSS
AND FILE THAT UNDER THE.
ANYONE WHO SAW THE DEBATE KNOWS
THAT.
EVERY DAY HE GOT A HIT ON A
BIBLE.
[LAUGHTER]
THE FACT IS HE IS A BILLIONAIRE
REAL ESTATE DEVELOPER IN NEW
YORK CITY.
YOU THINK HE NEVER HAD TO DEAL
WITH ACTUAL MAFIA BOSSES?
WHY DO YOU THINK HE IS THE WAY
HE IS NOW.
HE IS NOW SORRY, WHEN AMERICA
HEARS COMEY WIND THAT TRUMP IS
LIKE A MAFIA BOSS THEY GO, NO
[BLEEP], SHERLOCK.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT IS WHY WE LIKE HIM.
THINK ABOUT IT.
WOULD YOU RATHER HAVE DEALING
WITH THE LIKES OF NORTH KOREA O
WITH THE LIKES OF NORTH KOREA O-
WITH THE LIKES OF NORTH KOREA OS
WITH THE LIKES OF NORTH KOREA OM
WITH THE LIKES OF NORTH KOREA OO
WITH THE LIKES OF NORTH KOREA OE
WITH THE LIKES OF NORTH KOREA OW
WITH THE LIKES OF NORTH KOREA OO
WITH THE LIKES OF NORTH KOREA OR
WITH THE LIKES OF NORTH KOREA OM
WITH THE LIKES OF NORTH KOREA ON
WITH THE LIKES OF NORTH KOREA OS
WITH THE LIKES OF NORTH KOREA OY
WITH THE LIKES OF NORTH KOREA OU
WITH THE LIKES OF NORTH KOREA OO
WITH THE LIKES OF NORTH KOREA OF
THIS OR SOMEONE WHO REMINDS YOU
OF A GRAD SCHOOL PA POETRY TO
HIS CATS.
[LAUGHTER]
NOW, I DON'T KNOW THAT HE DOES
THAT AND OKAY IF I WERE TRUMP
AND ASKED ABOUT BEING CALLED A
MOB BOSS I MIGHT SAY I'M DEEPLY
FLATTERED AND THEN I WOULD HAND
OUT RED HAT THAT'S A MAFIA
INSTEAD OF [INAUDIBLE] AND WE
HAD THAT MADE.
TWENTY-FIVE DOLLARS IF YOU
WANTED BOTTOM LINE, IT COMES
DOWN TO ONE THAT.
THERE'S A CERTAIN KIND OF PERSON
DESIGNED TO BE PRESIDENT FROM
THE GET-GO AND THEY LOOK LIKE
THIS OR THIS OR THIS.
TRUMP IS NOT THEM AND HE IS
TRUMP.
SOMEONE UNACCUSTOMED TO THE
PURITY TEST ALL POLITICIANS CAN
FAKE WHICH IS WHY THE PUBLIC
DOESN'T CARE AND THEY KNOW WHAT
HE IS.
HE MAY BE A MAFIA BOSS BUT HE IS
OUR MAFIA BOSS.
[LAUGHTER]
THEY ARE APPLAUDING FOR THE
MAFIA.
WHILE THE MEDIA SPEWS CRAP HOW
DOES AMERICA FEEL ABOUT IT?
ALL OF THIS IS ABOUT BEHAVIOR
PRIOR TO ELECTION DESIGNED TO
UNSEAT A PRESIDENT BASED ON A
EMOTIONAL INJURY THAT OCCURRED
ON NOVEMBER 8, 2016.
WHAT UNITES ANTI- TROOPERS IS
PTSD, PRESIDENT TRUMP STRESS
DISORDER.
[LAUGHTER]
THE MEDIA SAYS TRUMP IS USING
POOR POLICY TO DISTRACT FROM
SCANDAL BUT IT'S THE OPPOSITE.
THE SCANDALS ARE DESIGNED TO
KEEP HIM FROM DOING HIS JOB AND
THAT IS HOW AMERICA
THAT IS HOW I SEE IT.
AND I AM AMERICA.
[LAUGHTER]
YES, I AM.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
I'M KIND OF SHAPE LIKE AMERICA
AND AMERICA WANTED TO KEEP DOING
HIS JOB BECAUSE SO FAR HE'S DONE
WITH CHINA, ISIS, TAXES AND WHAT
A STORY BUT THAT WOULD BE.
FIRST, AN OUTSIDER IS ELECTED TO
DISRUPT THE SYSTEM.
SECOND, HE ACTUALLY DISRUPT THE
SYSTEM, THIRD, THE MEDIA AND
THEIR DEMOCRATIC ENABLERS
WITHOUT FOR THE USE EVERYTHING
IN THEIR POWER TO REMOVE HIM.
NOW THEY SUCCEED THEY WILL
REMOVE ONE OF THE MOST RADICAL
POLITICAL FIGURES IN RECENT
MEMORY USING BEHAVIOR THAT WAS
PRIOR TO THE ELECTION.
ANTI- TRUMP, HAVE YOU THOUGHT
THIS THROUGH?
IF YOU'RE NOT CAREFUL YOU WILL
TURN TRUMP INTO A MASSIVE FOLK
HERO AND 70 MILLION PEOPLE WILL
BE AT YOUR DOORSTEP AND IT WILL
BE TO SEEING YOU GOT A FRIEND.
[LAUGHTER]
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
MY FAVORITE BUTCHER, SHE CUT
THROUGH THE BOLOGNA.
I ALMOST SAID SOMETHING ELSE.
JEDEDIAH.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
LIKE A WELL OILED STOPPING CART
HE WILL HAVE YOU ROLLING IN THE
AISLES, ACTOR, COMEDIAN JAMIE.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
SHE'S GOT MORE BAGGAGE THAN A
SAMSONITE SALESMAN.
KAT SIMS.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
AND HE HATES CEILING FANS.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK TYRUS.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
JEDEDIAH, A LOT HAPPEN THIS WEEK
AND CALL ME, COMEY, COMEY.
WHAT YOU MAKE OF THIS CONTRACT.
>> THE BOOK SOUNDS TERRIBLE.
I DIDN'T GET IT COPIED EITHER
BUT EVERY EXCERPT I READ MADE
HIM LESS AND LESS LIKABLE AS A
PERSON AND THIS GUY -- I MEAN,
HE STOOPED TO THE LOWEST LEVEL.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT TRUMP THAI
AND HIS UNDER EYE CIRCLES LIKE
IS IN A TANNING BED AND IT'S ANY
SHRED OF CREDIBILITY THAT THIS
GUY HAD, WHICH I DON'T KNOW HOW
HE COULD HAVE ANY AFTER NOT
INDICTING HILLARY CLINTON
FRANKLY, BUT ANY SHED THAT
REMAINS HAS BEEN LOST FROM THE
EXCERPT THAT I READ AND, YOU
KNOW,  THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE IN
THIS WORLD THAT WANT TO BE IN
FRONT AND CENTER OF THE CAMERA
ALL THE TIME AND THIS GUY IS ONE
OF THEM.
ANY OPPORTUNITY LIKE SOMEONE HAD
HIM A SHOW BECAUSE HE'S BEGGING
FOR IT.
THAT IS WHAT HE WANTS.
GREG: WHAT, TYRUS?
TYRUS: YOU BETTER NOT.
I WARNED YOU ABOUT HILLARY ON
SUNDAY AND IF KOBE GETS ONE I'M
DONE.
I'M OUT.
GREG: HERE'S MY SUNDAY LINEUP.
YOU GOT HILLARY AT 8:00 O'CLOCK
BECAUSE THAT PROVIDES FODDER FOR
"FOX AND FRIENDS" THE NEXT DAY
FOLLOWED BY COMEY AND IT'S
CALLED THE COMEY CONFESSIONAL.
[LAUGHTER]
SORRY, TYRUS.
JAMIE,
JAMIE --
>> WHAT ABOUT THE FREDA FILES?
BECAUSE OF THE THINGS BEFORE --
A GODFATHER, I BELIEVE IT WAS.
GREG: WHAT YOU MAKE OF HIS
RESPONSE?
>> I HONESTLY THOUGHT HE MAY BE
OVERREACTED.
WHY EVEN RESPOND TO --
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
IT IS A TELL-ALL BOOK AND REALLY
DO PEOPLE DO WHAT TELLS BOOK.
IT'S ALL OF IT AND I THOUGHT THE
THING ABOUT I THOUGHT TRUMP
SHOULD HAVE LET IT ROLL OFF THE
SHOULDERS ESPECIALLY THE THING
ABOUT THE STORY THAT WAS IN
THERE RUSSIA AND THE PROSTITUTES
AND I THOUGHT SHOULD MAKE AN
EXCUSE AND SAID IT'S NOT WHAT
EVERYONE THANKS AND I JUST DON'T
SPEAK FLUENT RUSSIAN AND THEY
COMPLETELY MISUNDERSTAND ME.
I WALKED IN IT WAS LIKE WHAT ARE
YOU GUYS DOING AND I SAID
THERE'S A LEAK IN THE STATE.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: THAT WOULD WORK.
>> I SAID WE SHOULD GET THREE
HOT PLUMBERS NOT THREE HOT
PROSTITUTES.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT'S MY IDEA.
GREG: THAT IS VERY GOOD.
CAT, WHAT YOU MAKE OF THIS BOOK
SEVEN THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
READING POETRY TO YOUR CAT, GREG
READING POETRY TO YOUR CAT, GRE
GREG, FIRST OF ALL.
GREG: THAT'S WHAT YOU GOT FROM
THIS P7 THAT'S WHAT I GOT FROM
YOUR MONOLOGUE.
GREG: THAT WAS DIRECTED TO
INSULT YOU SEVEN I THOUGHT SO.
I AGREE WITH JEDEDIAH.
SHE MADE COMMENTS ABOUT THE TINY
HANDS AND ARE BE DONE WITH A
TINY HANDS YET THAT'S LIKE THE
BIGGEST HACK JOKE IN THE WORLD
AND I'M SURPRISED THAT THE NEXT
SENTENCE WASN'T WHY DIDN'T THE
CHICKEN CROSS THE ROAD THAT'S
HOW HACKETT WAS.
YOU'RE NOT REGINA GEORGE AND YOU
ARE A FORMER FBI DIRECTOR AND
YOU CAN ACT LIKE A GROWN-UP.
HE WANTS TO BE REGINA GEORGE.
GREG: WAS REGINA GEORGE?
SEVEN MEAN GIRL.
GREG: I WAS NOT INTENDING I KNEW
WHO WAS.
>> I WAS AFRAID THE CAMERA WAS
ON ME TO.
>> IT IS.
GREG: TYRUS, WHAT YOU MAKE OF
THE WHOLE -- WHAT IS WRONG WITH
HAVING A MAFIA BOSS IS THE
PRESIDENT?
TYRUS: WELL, AS LONG AS HIS NAME
IS ALFREDO IT'S NOT TOO BAD.
HERE'S THE THING, OBVIOUSLY FROM
THE DAY THEY MET TRUMP AND COMEY
DID NOT LIKE EACH OTHER.
IT'S NOT A MATCH MADE IN HEAVEN
AND HE FELT HE WAS FIRED BY
SOMEONE WHO WAS INFERIOR TO HIM
SO THAT THE ANGER COMES FROM.
I AM WILLING TO SUGGEST THAT IF
WE GOT OUR HANDS ON THE BOOK
THAT WASN'T CUT AND PASTED BY
THE LIBERAL MEDIA THAT MIGHT BE
A BETTER READ.
I THINK THEY'RE DOING A
DISSERVICE AND I HAVE NOT SEEN
THE BOOK BUT THEY ARE TAKING
PIECES OUT AND FORMING A
DIFFERENT THING.
I THINK THEY'RE MAKING HIM AND I
THINK THAT DOING A HORRIBLE THE
SERVICE TO COMEY BECAUSE YOU
HAVE NOT READ THE BOOK AND I'M
NOT SAYING HE'S OBVIOUSLY
BETTER.
LISTEN, IF I GOT FIRED BY A GUY
SMALLER THAN ME THAT I COULD
BEAT UP I MIGHT, I MIGHT, I
MIGHT WHEN MY BOOK COMES OUT SAY
SOME TERRIBLE THINGS ABOUT HIS
ANIMAL CHOICES THAT AREN'T REAL.
[LAUGHTER]
ARE THAT HEAP BUT SCHOOLS AROUND
THE OFFICE THAT I TRIP OVER AND
I MIGHT HAVE ISSUES WITH SOME
THINGS THAT I GET IN UNDERSTAND
THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN FIRED AND